لم أكن أتوقع أنه سيكون هناك
مثل هذا
الجهد القوي للتأكد من
أن الشيء الأكثر أهمية هو أن
الرئيس بايدن لم ينجز أي شيء.
الديمقراطيون للفوز في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي لعام 2022 إذا كان يريد أي أمل في دفع
أجندته السياسية إلى الأمام ، لكن
حزب الرئيس يفقد دائمًا
مقاعده في انتخابات التجديد النصفي ، وتحومت نسبة تأييد بايدن
حول 40 في
المائة منذ بداية
العام وهذا لا يبشر  حسنًا بالنسبة
لبقية حزبه ،
وبعبارة أخرى ، قد يكون الإبقاء على الكونجرس
معركة شاقة ، وآمل
أن تكون الانتخابات الـ22 بمثابة استفتاء
على أداء الإدارة الحالية ،
فماذا
تعني السلطة الجمهورية في الكونجرس
جيدًا؟
سيتم إيقاف جدول الأعمال السياسي تمامًا ،
فهو يواجه بالفعل صعوبة في الحصول على
أي شيء يتم تمريره.
إذا خسروا حتى عددًا قليلاً من
المقاعد في عام 2022 ، فإن الجمهوريين
سيستعيدون السلطة ويوقفون بايدن في مساراته
، فسيتم حظر الجزء الأكبر من أجندة سياسة بايدن
بما في ذلك أشياء مثل
حزمة تشريعات حقوق التصويت المتعلقة بالمناخ
والتحكم في الأسلحة على
طول الخط نفسه الذي سيجده الجمهوريون
أيضًا.  من الصعب الحصول على أي شيء
ثم توقيعه في النهاية على
القانون من قبل الرئيس بيدن ، والشيء الآخر
الذي يأتي مع الأغلبية الجديدة هو
أنك قادر على مساءلة هذه الإدارة
بالسلطة الجمهورية في المنزل ، مما يعني
أن الجمهوريين سيكونون الآن مسؤولين
عن لجان التحقيق و  قد
يتابعون عددًا كبيرًا من التحقيقات التي
كانوا يهددونها بأشياء مثل
التحقيقات في صائد نجل بايدن
إلى تعامل البيت الأبيض مع
الحدود الجنوبية لانسحاب بايدن
من أفغانستان لإغلاق
اللجنة المختارة في 6 يناير / كانون الثاني التي قام بها بعض
أعضاء اليمين المتطرف.  حتى قالوا
إنهم سيحاولون إطلاق
إجراءات عزل ضد الرئيس في
جمهورية قصيرة  إن تولي السيطرة على
الكونجرس في عام 2022 سيجعل
السنتين الأخيرتين من فترة ولاية بايدن الأولى في
المنصب مؤلمة قدر الإمكان
للديمقراطيين.